من بعد ما كانت غايبه عن الموسم الرمضاني
2022 هذا الموسم بيطل علينا في مسلسل
واخيرا اللي بيشاركها في البطوله الفنان
قصي خولي وحقيقه في كل عمل بيعملوه مع بعض
بيحققوا ثنائيه جميله وبيفاجئوا محبينهم
مره بعد مره مسلسل واخيرا عمل الدعوه هو
هذا عمل درامي اجتماعي مليان تشويق واثاره
وبيتكلم عن قصه حب بين خيال اللي هي نادين
نجيم وياقوت اللي هو قصي وبيستعرض صعوبات
ومشاكل بتواجه الثنائي والمسلسل المحقق
نجاحات كبيره ترى من اول حلقه له فهو
الاكثر مشاهده على منصه شاهد في عدد من
الدول العربيه
[تصفيق]
قصتنا يعود منها سابقه
[موسيقى]
عشان معنا
لكن رغم النجاح الكبير يبدو انه نادين مو
راضيه كثير عن العمل وفاجات كل الناس على
تويتر باكثر من تغريدا انتقدت فيها بنفسها
مسلسلها والسبب بحسب كلامها انه في مشاهد
محذوفه كلوزات مثل ما قالت ان رمت من دون
اي تبرير وقالت انه هذا الشيء بخليها تحس
بالقهر لانه بتشتغل من قلبها هي وبتلاقي
النتيجه شيء ثانيه وعلى فكره اللي بتقوله
نادين كنا سمعنا اصوات بتقولوا على تويتر
فشفنا بعض التعليقات على التقطيع في
المسلسل واختيار زوايا التصوير